-There's new music
in the works for you.
A few weeks ago, you were here.
You performed...
♪ Don't go yet, oh-oh-oh ♪
-♪ Heeeey ♪
-♪ Don't go ♪
-And we made so
many TikToks together.
-We did!
I love that you did that.
-I felt bad. I was like,
"Can we do this one?
And can we do this one?
Can we do this one?"
-No, you're the most fun.
Come on.
But also, I found out
a little trivia
about that song, "Don't Go Yet."
Who helped write that song
that we don't know?
-Well, like, I'm sure, a
lot of people in the audience --
I don't know if this was your
experience, Jimmy, but I got
a little COVID puppy.
He's a golden retriever,
and his name is Tarzan.
And he was in my house,
and he just, like, barged
into the studio.
And I was with Mike Sabbath
and Scott Harris,
who I wrote the song with,
and Mike Sabbath was like --
It was actually in this room,
and he kind of ran in here.
And Mike Sabbath was like...
♪ Oh, he's on the track ♪
♪ This is fire ♪
And he was recording,
and he put it in the song.
And those kind of notes
and the way that, like,
the tune kind of
made his voice sound
sounded like
the chorus melody of...
♪ Oh, don't go yet ♪
And so, that inspired
the chorus of the song, and --
-Here he is.
-When you're songwriting,
if you don't have a chorus,
you, like, don't really
have a song.
So he kind of wrote it.
-I love --
-He's a genius. He's a star.
-He's a genius.
Tarzan, great wri--
He's probably watching tonight.
Great work, buddy.
-Mommy loves you.
You know, I actually --
Do you follow Tarzan
on his Instagram account?
He has an Instagram account
called @Tarzandadog.
-Yeah, of course.
Yeah, of course I do.
-Uh --
-Are you kidding me? Yeah.
-He has the best posts, bro.
You've gotta follow him, man.
-"TarzanTheDog"?
-No, "D-A."
"Tarzandadog."
-Yeah, "Tarzandadog."
-Lorde has her
onion rings account.
I got my dog account.
-Yeah, exactly. Good.
Can we talk about the album?
What's the theme of this album
when it comes out?
-The theme of the album --
The album is called "Familia."
And I think, like,
just my love of food
and having people kind of gather
around a dinner table
prompted me kind of manifesting
just having a squad around
and having friends around
and friends being kind of like
your chosen family.
Plus, also, your real family.
But it basically --
Just being about community.
You know, I feel like
so much in our culture,
it's like, you know, there's --
there's independence
and, you know --
very kind of, like,
based on the individual.
And I think this album, for me,
was a lot about interdependence
and community and, uh --
And my dog wrote
all the songs.
-[ Laughs ] That's not true.
That's not true.
Can we tell people
when to maybe expect it, or no?
-You know what?
I feel like I was gonna say --
My goal is the fall,
but obviously, you never know
what's gonna happen
in the world.
But it is finished, so the fall.
-Camila Cabello,
everybody.
-[ Laughs ]
-"Familia"!
"Familia" is coming soon.
And check out "Cinderella"
on Amazon Prime Video
starting on September 3rd.
We love you.